E aí
[Música]
a primeira vez na história A Hierarquia
do conhecimento foi rompida porque até
revolução digital conhecimento ele
necessariamente vinha do doutor para o
mestre pela Universidade preciso
superior ensino básico e depois que os
custos não regulamentados mas hoje em
dia com a revolução digital a gente sabe
esses dois adolescentes 500 na garagem
da casa dos pais são capazes de lançar
uma inovação que vai impactar a
sociedade mudar a forma como ela percebe
uma
Oi e essa inversão na cultura do
conhecimento tem gerado no problema
Seríssimo para as escolas que estão
tendo muita dificuldade para acompanhar
o ritmo tecnológico jovens e para
identificar esse compasso né trouxe aqui
nós temos para vocês na década de 1990
para dar cada que eu fui uma criança
para gente Assistir Teletubbies a gente
tem que esperar o dia do Teletubbies a
hora que ele passar a gente tinha que ir
para sala que tinha a TV ligada vendo
canal que passava a Letônia e só com a
junção de todas as variáveis a gente
conseguir fazer o telefone da acontecer
tô aqui hoje em dia na década de 2020
não é essa a gente acabou de inaugurar é
completamente diferente nas crianças
Assistir Teletubbies elas o que elas
quiserem né No dia que elas quiserem na
hora que elas fizeram lugar quando
quiserem não plataforma que elas
quiserem com dispositivo que elas
tiverem então na década de 90 a gente
conseguia pegar aquela criança que
Assistir Teletubbies
e colocar dentro de uma sala de aula
incinerar e Forçar ela prestar atenção
que o professor decide ensinar e não que
ela escolheu aprender agora na década de
2000 Lins não vai mais conseguir fazer
isso aí como é que a gente pegar e
acelerar doutrinar essas crianças que em
casa em toda essa liberdade de escolha
acostumadas a tomar indecisão não vai
mais dar se não vai mais conseguir esse
descompasso entre a evolução tecnológica
e os métodos escola tem gerado um choque
geracional entre professores e alunos na
esse choque ele começou na década de 90
na década de 2000 ele cresceu na década
de 2010 ele ficou difícil de disfarçar e
nessa década de 2020 se as escolas não
mudaram os métodos dela não atualizaram
os métodos da educação correm sério
risco de entrar em colapso porque os
jovem não vão mais encaixar nessa
educação e isso é um problema Seríssimo
porque se isso acontecer se a educação
um mês que a gente despertar o potencial
Tecnológico de toda essa geração com
Brasil vai enfrentar um dos problemas
internacionais mais graves da história
o segundo o historiador israelense e
oval Hari no mundo tá vivendo essa
corrida armamentista pela Inteligência
Artificial pra gente tem China Estados
Unidos que estão na frente né dos países
ficando para trás então quê que vai ser
na nossa economia né da nossa indústria
do nosso serviço representa oitenta e
dois por cento do PIB vi quando boa
parte delas podem completamente
automatizados por Inteligência
Artificial de propriedade estrangeira e
tem outra coisa pior ainda Vale do
Silício tá lá colocamos nossos dados né
que que vai ser da nossa economia quando
ele souber em tudo nos nossos políticos
dos nossos jornalistas dos nossos juízes
inclusive na as traições as condições a
fraqueza mentais Será que a gente ainda
vai ser um país independente ou será que
a gente vai se tornar uma comunidade
porque quando você tem dados suficientes
então se eu mandar soldados para contar
uma país
e como brasileira eu tô um pouquinho
preocupada com a situação deixa contar
um pouco da minha história pra vocês
assim quando eu fundo Startup chamada
splurge que a gente já sabe para a
aceleração da aprendizagem que a gente
pegava a videira cognitivo usuários
processava né e gerava roteiros de
estudos utilizados para eles e aí
acertavam eram medtec no Startup da área
de tecnologia a gente conversou a
grelhar as startups de Educação de
Brasília também a gente combinou esse
movimento é chamado é detectável que
hoje é o movimento que conta com 68
espaçados na educação e aí astrologia
foi continuada mas vai estar com tal
como contraposição de continua fazendo
mimi tanto no passado e fez não vende
para 800 gestores nacionais e eu tava
vendo disso eu falei vemos de
aglomerações pois chegou Nós Dois
Vizinhos de um nocaute em todas as
minhas contas fontes de receita na que
completamente sem renda com conta para
pagar não sei que você faz nessa
situação melhor do que você faz com que
você
a cola uma situação dessa dá o que eu
fiz foi entrar em vespeiro e era lá todo
momento mesmo né eu começo a academia
estava em causa assim terror e Pânico a
ordem do dia especialmente nas escolas
eles soltaram a barata no salão né que
tava mesa e cadeira de cabeça para o ar
poeira foi lá Confusão Para todo lado e
no meio de toda essa bagunça uma
diretora de escola me livro ele fala
Natália
tu sabe que eu Naninha aqui na escola tá
que pode dar aí o problema que ele tinha
era aqui pai estava reclamando das aulas
na eles queriam entregar aulas mais
interessantes vontade hoje que eu tenho
com certeza não sabe que eu tô
precisando disso mas a minha voz da
minha consciência me interrompeu para me
lembrar que eu nunca tinha sido uma
consultora né Tia você vai primeira vez
e era um momento muito delicado porque a
sua intervenção foi já dá certo mas fala
dessa errado ela podia dar muito errado
e acabar com o restinho de carreira que
ainda assim mas eu tomei a decisão né
aceitei esse desafio mais do que isso
assim agarrei esse desafio com maior
desafio da minha vida raro Isso é uma
consultora Educacional na escola de
verdade eu tenho super rock n' roll E aí
eu tava já cinco anos estudando todo
esse paradigma da nova educação no olho
do furacão das inovações tecnológicas E
locacionais então chega com tudo e aí
para gente conseguir acertar o ponteiro
dessa escola
o ano de dois milhões a gente ia ter que
usar a tecnologia a favor da Inovação
então pensei a gente vai precisar de uma
ferramenta uma ferramenta o primeiro né
que deixasse o aluno ativo no processo
de aprendizagem que ele fosse
protagonista da aprendizagem dele e não
simplesmente casa recebendo as
informações do professor segundo a gente
precisar de uma ferramenta que fizesse o
professor sem Professor aumentou que ele
descesse do pau começou a transitar
entre os alunos guiando aprendizagem e
despertando a curiosidade de seus alunos
igual Montessori Steiner vigotski mal
abuso e paixão em vários outros
educadores mundialmente reconhecidos vem
falando há mais de século a gente também
é precisar de uma ferramenta aqui
obviamente funcionasse o ensino remoto
né estava meio de um poder ir que
permitisse colaboratividade mas não só
colaboratividade permitisse
colaboratividade em tempo real e aí a
gente também é precisar de uma
ferramenta que desenvolver essas
competências socioemocionais que são as
competências do Século 21 a gente também
apesar de uma ferramenta que
desenvolvesse outras é
é importante para o Terceiro Milênio e
como design e tecnologia só isso aí eu
gosto olhei lá no mundo de ferramenta
sensacionais para ver se encontrava
alguma coisa não encontrei eu fui achar
uma ferramenta no mundo do Design e do
desenvolvimento de produtos digitais e
eu encontrei o filme O signo uma
ferramenta de prototipação né ele ele é
usado pela ordem e pela nubank pelo Uber
para desenvolver as interfaces que a
gente interagem aplicativo sites né
interface então fica ele não é só um
programa tecnológico ele é um problema
usado para criar tecnologia né o Sigma
ele é tecnologia na veia e isso é
aplicado no contexto Educacional
significa um quadro negro 500 vezes mais
potentes né você pegar professor e aluno
hoje tá todo mundo dentro de um arquivo
gráfico e todo mundo ele tem voz e giz
mas não é qualquer jeito ali a gente
realmente Podia colocar vários tipos
assim infinidade de metodologias ativas
e baseados na empresa trouxe alguns
exemplos para ilustrar isso por exemplo
Esse foi um exercício de genética você
tinha que ir lá no quadrinho de genótipo
e fenótipo e com base nessas
características você montavam
dragãozinho outro exercício sequer um
Brainstorm de mapa da empatia então eles
pegaram praticante de Cyber bullying né
e começaram fazer um instrumento que que
ele pensa que ele ver o que que ele diz
né O que que ele ouve Esse aqui foi
super trunfo dos Mestres do xadrez isso
super trunfo não existisse ótimo para
você reforçar parâmetros informações
factuais dá para fazer com qualquer
matéria e aí a gente também tem um
exercício de literatura sobre o livro O
Fantasma de canterville que eles tinham
que mostrar a casinha né conforme os
episódios do livro e acha que é um jogo
que o professor desenha alguma coisa os
alunos tem que tentar acertar o quê que
está sendo desenhado né Quem acertar
primeiro ganha um ponto e esse aqui foi
o jogo de tabuleiro desenvolvido por
alunos do sétimo ano não é cada casa
tinha uma pergunta sobre locução E aí
você tinha que acertar as perguntas e
isso aqui foi um pulmão criado e animado
do zero
é do 6º ano portanto ao longo de 11 anos
aqui eu trouxe gente uma pincelada do
que aconteceu em uma escola Nesses
últimos quatro meses né com professores
e alunos de 10 a 14 anos agora imagina o
que que vai acontecer quando várias
comunidades escolares tiverem a
verdadeira influência neste tipo de
tecnologia né porque que eles não vão
criar aí para educação então voltando lá
no tempo para nenhum desses exercícios
existir eu cheguei lá na escola e eu
falei você esse lobo é mais daqui Moraes
Rego Seria a primeira escola do Brasil a
usar o Sigma para metodologias ativas
o EA recepção foi um pouco dramática é
para colocar em perspectiva Sem Ar uma
consultora 100% inexperientes né que a
gente faz alguma coisa pela primeira vez
na história então Lógico que as pessoas
e feijão isso ele não colocar a mão na
massa para fazer isso né receberam de
uma forma cética trazer pouco né e assim
elas estavam desgastados né ela já tinha
tive que aprender vários problemas nessa
migração para online então quando eu
fiquei insistindo na cidade a gente não
precisa mais uma ferramenta vou prender
as tensões foram escalando escalando
escalando e rolando um abaixo-assinado
na escola contra filho conta na hora que
eu tinha possuem uma resistência
declarada contra a Inovação não foram
todos os professores mas isso deu Tom né
porque tava acontecendo lá na escola e
vários fatores contribuíram para isso né
primeiros professores realmente estavam
sobrecarregados segundo eles
desconfiaram disse que eu tava fazendo
terceiro sem abordagem que eu usei
talvez não não tenha sido a melhor mas
tem um Outro fator que é um fator mais
difícil né de admitir
o medo da tecnologia né você só a frio
diante da possibilidade tem que aprender
uns ao Sertão certificado e usar ele com
crianças e adolescentes podendo perder o
controle da turma né porque afinal de
contas A Hierarquia do conhecimento foi
quebrado só que a gente não dá mais para
esperar se a gente continuar a gente não
enfrentar esse esse medo da tecnologia o
choque geracional ele vai sempre ar nós
vamos eles estão sedentos por se
desenvolverem em tecnologia em software
e programação E se a gente não
incentivar isso a gente vai estrangula o
desenvolvimento deles e vai despertar o
potencial de toda uma geração seja fazer
isso com as contas gerações não dá mais
astral e falando isso assim eu fiz uma
pesquisa nesse sentido no ano passado eu
fiz um palestra sobre inovação
executivas na estação em várias cidades
professores e gestores educacionais
nessas palestras eu falava aqui as
indústrias né de forma geral leitinho
evoluído estrondosamente nos últimos 100
anos na finance
a aplicação de transporte 7 só que a
educação parecia estar congelada lá na
primeira revolução industrial que foi
quando ela foi concebida E aí eu
perguntava para esses professores e
gestores na opinião de vocês que que tá
acontecendo né é o que que tá impedindo
a Inovação e eu de 6 alternativas o
aluno o professor o gestor tecnologia
orçamento e regulamentação EA resposta
foi muito clara em primeiro lugar o que
tá impedindo e inovação na educação é
orçamento e segurar professor em
terceiro lugar gestor esses três fatores
juntos somos setenta por cento da
responsabilidade ou seja segundo 600
professores e gestores educacionais o
que tá impedindo a Inovação na escola na
depois da falta de dinheiro são eles
mesmo nossa dizendo foram ele né Isso é
fácil de entender porque esses
profissionais e se percebem como leigos
em tecnologia e faltou interior né do
processo de inovação é a adoção de
Tecnologia da
bom então eu tava né passando faça
batata quente na mão você fiquei
preocupadíssima nossa época vai
assassinado assim eu andava de um lado
para o outro no meu quarto é
praticamente fiz um Rastro no chão de
preocupação né O que que eu vou fazer
assim lembranças ficar uma consultora
ele experientes não era minha primeira
vez Então abaixo-assinado contra que eu
tava fazendo na escola ver negócio um
pouco forte para mim poderia ter-me
derrubado eles quase me derrubou só que
eu tinha me comprometido para fazer né
uma transformação então não ia desistir
até que eu consegui fazer essa
transformação e nessas minhas andanças
de um lado para o outro no meu quarto é
eu me dei conta de que não precisava
capacitar os professores para esse
projeto efetivamente ter sucesso dentro
da escola a gente teria passado todo
mundo né professor coordenador aluno e
pais e alunos que eu vou usar uns
novinhos e eu me dei conta de que uma
pessoa não ia conseguir né treinar todo
mundo a gente vai precisar de vários
monitores só que elas oportunidades
aulas todas as adversidades não é
justamente porque a gente precisava de
vários monitores e não 2
O mãe não tem dinheiro para contratar
esse tanto a solução ficou evidente
os funcionários alunos professores não
queriam começar a transformação que a
gente podia tentar né e pela Via dos
alunos e eu chamei eles galera seguinte
e tenta ferramenta super sofisticada que
pode mudar para sempre a forma como
vocês aprendem não tem ninguém no brasil
fazendo isso talvez ela tá no mundo
O que vocês acham pega os primeiros a
um grave hoje que a gente quer por favor
Com certeza pelo amor de Deus eu já que
a alcinha eu quero fazer parte disso né
E aí ia mexer com super monitores a
gente fez a formação dessa garotada ele
se desenvolveram muito rápido aprenderam
É Como Era esperado e no final dessa
formação a gente resolveu fazer uma é um
seminário para mostrar para toda a
escola o super projeto de inovação
estava acontecendo aí dentro e aí cada
grupo teria que desenvolver uma
atividade game ficada com propósito
Claro com objetivo Claro de aprendizagem
e repara a diferença na hora pegar um
jogo pronto e importar para escola eram
as crianças desenvolvendo o próprio jogo
artesanalmente nelas confeccionando
igual a boa velha e linha montessoriana
só que adaptada para O Terceiro Milênio
e a gente fez Esse seminário é assim
coisas super sucesso que são cinco
porcento da enxurrada de elogios que a
gente recebeu e a interessante
reconhecer que foram os alunos que
salvaram né A transformação se não
fossem eles projeto já tinha sido
interrompido lá atrás e aí a gente na
superou a sua primeira etapa
hei de conquistar a escola só que aí
agora sim né que os desafios começaram
de verdade tá gente é super monitores
mas como é que a gente ia fazer para
engajar todo mundo nessa transformação
EA chamei a meninada e joguei esse para
eles gente aí qual que é o plano ele
dorme daí brilhante Vamos fazer uma
gincana uma gincana toda no Sigma 100%
online tem por cento colaborativa 100%
em tempo real igual a ninguém nunca fez
E essa era uma ideia simplesmente
brilhante porque quem é que resiste né
adrenalina de uma gincana e foi aí que a
mágica começou a acontecer porque os
professores ele já tinha começado a se
sensibilizar lá no seminário e quando
chegou essa ideia da gincana ele se
empolgaram ele se envolveram de uma
forma que eu não esperava né foi muito
bonito ver aquela disposição para dar
ideia para jogo se voluntariar né para
ser juiz para vocês firme começaram a
marcar a monitoria Aliás a escola
inteira começou a marcar muito em outras
preparar para a gincana e foi realmente
lindo ver se sente
a colaboratividade surgir na escola ela
foi muito lindo ver os professores
começando a superar na resistência que
eles tinham por Tailândia pelo amor que
eles tinham pelos estudantes que era
muito Evidente nós professores são seres
apaixonados quando ele se darão conta de
que era importante para os estudantes
Então se tornou importante para eles e a
gente se juntou e fez a gincana com
enorme sucesso aqui também alguns Jardim
é só pra dar o gostinho da Diversão tem
batalha naval teve caça ao tesouro a
gente fez também uma guerra de peões que
é uma adaptação de xadrez teve está
indica um concurso de soletração a gente
vai ter bolinho também que é uma espécie
de jogo de perguntas e respostas teve um
o né guerra dos universos que há uma
adaptação do Ó teve também agora sempre
faço parte mais legal encostou de design
nas crianças as equipes aulas tem que
desenvolver um parte às vezes ainda esse
Parque depois justificar as decisões que
elas tomaram
Boa tarde Irene Isso sim é uma das
provas era construir O protótipo
funcional de um aplicativo com vários
requisitos de sistema complexo em 7
horas
tô falando de alunos de 10 a 14 anos meu
super mentores né trairão óbvio né seis
e aí a gente conseguiu a gente conseguiu
juntar a professores e alunos dentro
desse propósito né de transformação
tecnológica por meio do espírito
esportivo e quando a gente fez isso né a
gente conseguiu juntar também a gerações
Baby boomers X Y Z e reduzir aquele
ruído do Choque geracional como os
professores começaram a superar esse
medo que eles tinham da tecnologia
surgiu a esperança de que a gente também
superasse os obstáculos para Inovar em
educação surgiu esperanças de
classificação se atualizar e se
sincronizar se com os outros setores da
economia também surgiu a esperança né
gente a gente diz estrangula se o
desenvolvimento tecnológico dos jovens e
que talvez a gente conseguisse preservar
a nossa dignidade de tal sem se tornar
uma colônia de dados e a ideia é muito
simples né o segredo não é você tentar
promover uma transformação ou só de cima
para baixo ao diretor toma decisão gente
vai acontecer uma transformação na
escola ótimo
e para coordenador para professor para
aluno que depois vai impactar lá para o
pai né esse modelo é frágil porque os
professores eles têm dificuldade com
tecnologia o segredo a gente promoveu
uma transformação bidirecional tem um
diretor Ele toma decisão a gente vai
fazer a ultrassom ração na escola ele
passa isso para cortando eu faça isso
por isso professores Mas ele também
capacita os alunos para que essas duas
gerações se encontrem e juntas elas
consigam lutar pela transformação
e sim ao longo de todo o sistema
educacional né toda a história do
sistema operacional sempre foram os
adultos que ensinarão as crianças mas
pela primeira vez na história uma
reforma é a primeira vez na história que
está acontecendo A Hierarquia do
conhecimento foi rompida pela primeira
vez na história as crianças têm um
conhecimento que os adultos não tem isso
significa que pela primeira vez elas
podem ensinar aos adultos algo que eles
não sabem especialmente num país em
desenvolvimento como o Brasil a gente
precisa da Ajuda das Crianças em poder a
essas crianças para que elas consigam
promover a revolução das escolas porque
sozinhos né Nós adultos não vamos
conseguir e quem foi que disse que
criança não pode salvar a pátria
enquanto ainda é criança chegou a hora
da gente recrutar essa garotada para
lutar pelo nosso país e a boa notícia ai
ai né ótima notícia aquele série Natal
material
E aí